[Music]
so sleep basically wrote a piece about
you after this whole thing right and it
really was kind of straw matting what
you did but the attacks were also kind
of personal and that's there's always
it's an interesting you know when salon
goes after New Year's you or slate goes
out to me or you or Sam Harris whoever
they go after there's a kind of animus
there's a kind of personal attack that
is not just a an engagement of the hey
look you know you did this this is why
it's not right right you know it's not
oh yeah maybe it's funny but you're
wrong about this and here's why of any
plea personal attack on someone's like I
called them on the phone I think I
emailed them at least one twice few
times and I said look you guys wrote
this about me I would like an
opportunity to respond to this mmm
nothing then I went on Twitter and I
said hey can I please have an
opportunity fine I won't say I know the
exact wording was but can i I'd like an
opportunity nothing I would like an
opportunity that's a nice thing in
journalism like you just write hit
pieces on someone and then you don't
give an out to 1918 a I think it is I
think what's starting to happen is that
because journalism because mainstream
journalism is crumbling yeah I still use
that that adjective there and and nobody
cares about CNN anymore and even the New
York Times I think has gone in a really
terrible direction because they love a
lot of the ideas that you're talking
about but since the institutions are
crumbling well now everybody just picks
their website that that's ours
those websites are funded by all sorts
of different things and if you've got an
editor who has bought in to your
postmodern [ __ ] in their case well
you know you could say whatever the hell
you want about Pete or Dave or whoever
else yeah and you're going to get
backing so for this whole craziness that
happened with William mother Joseph yeah
and truce to sit and remove from that
right right which is literal format and
to present for this editor so they the
title of the thing was about the the new
extreme is further to that right now we
have to talk about that so you have
talking about have to be out of your
mind or or just a liar of the highest
order to think that of me you can hear
you can criticize me for all you want i
address criticism on here people think I
don't have any question yeah Ronnie and
it's not just that he's a terrible
journalist he has a
religious mindset like this is a
religion to these people so that so
that's the interesting thing so then I
went on the full-on
I mean I was like you know what you
picked the wrong person to [ __ ] with
right and I went on the absolute attack
I was defended publicly by you and Rogan
and a whole slew of other people to the
tens of thousands of retweets and things
of that and then various two days ago he
was writing about how Noah he doesn't
believe I'm an extremist but he doesn't
a debt you know there's no public
correction they do slight things at the
end of the article that no one can ever
see Wikipedia is still run with the real
thing he knows I tagged the editor this
woman Clara Jeffrey and all the in all
the tweets she never responds she's
never gotten this much Twitter
attraction but they don't feel a need to
because they know that their monster is
just going to keep moving forward and
that's what I'm trying to figure out the
answer so just to be clear you and so
what did he say about your show would
well solve it the title and you can look
at this maybe it still is pin tweet
right now though I suspect he's either
deleted it or removed it altogether was
something about the rise of the new
extremism or the newest extremists that
are further to the right than Breitbart
then he includes me in that where he
refers to me as far-right then
eventually changed that to just right
right which is the right less thing
doesn't need to make any sense anymore I
can put all that aside as I mentioned
that the top Forbes called this a
conservative show last week I've said to
you I think you were the first one I
ever said it to that defending my
liberal principle is becoming a
conservative position so all of these
labels are starting to make no sense and
that's just what's happened here that
and that's their thing so a couple of
things here if you had an itemized
checklist if you just write your beliefs
down in a check you and I would both
overwhelmingly fall into the liberal
camp not the left camp right so that's
why I'm saying liberal is not left that
is the chromatics mistake to make but
just to be clear for you yeah so without
naming the person who wrote the article
the guy who wrote the article out of me
yeah Josh Harkins in' okay yeah is Josh
invited on your show I invited
immediately I said I like know if he's
still invited on your show and he wrote
something sorry lifer
first I said you come on my show I'll
give you the first ten minutes without
talking he didn't respond to that then
today finally days later I responded
again to the day we're taping this exam
is awesome when we're airing it but
today I wrote you know will you come on
the show you hack so then I was being a
little more heavy-handed under all I
won't come on could you call me a name
but I really wouldn't come on
so the hacker I was just excuse me but
yeah but you said just to be completely
clear I invited gonna fit here 10 minute
me so you come on you can sit here in 10
minutes I will sit here and I was making
and I invited the editor too by the way
she's welcome to come on all that but
but in an odd way
maybe that and someone pointed this out
to me on the other one of the strange
odd same voices said Dave that would be
the worst thing you could do because
what you're doing is you're encouraging
more people to do things you're
encouraging people to say crazy things
about you you then getting a huff puff
and you got to defend yourself and now
what's the next thing now you got a you
got a sit and take it on your own show
which is so completely against the ideas
that you care about like I don't want my
life to be that you know you mean and
that's I want my life to be that either
yeah so it's an odd the community it is
and yet you don't want to just ignore it
it's against human nature to be attacked
and to just sit down and take that's why
we talked before about you have to
figure out whose voices matter no and
and I mean I don't know anything about
this guy but does his voice matter to
you I mean is this guy's opinion no hit
keys it utterly irrelevant to me but he
wrote a piece in a publication that had
saw so so the publication has had
relevance and by the way this guy as I
mentioned is a topple so he was one of
40 people that the Virginia GOP baseball
game shooter followed yeah so we know
that that guy was was riled up by a lot
of the political stuff he was reading
because you could just live on his
Facebook and all that to see that and
how much he hated Republicans whatever
so if you're calling me an extremist
there's a cost now that ideas and
intentions matter which is why I think
you can attack the hell out of ideas and
you did not can you should you know what
doesn't mean you should be instigating
violence and and therein lies the rub
mmm how do you feel now about all this
now that's been a
a day behind you and did you feel angry
when it happened on Friday I was I was
livid I was in New York City and I was
walking me in the middle of Times Square
so I'm in Times Square the craziest
place on earth like you know stimulation
bananas and whatever and I'm just
flicking off Twitter and I'm calling
people and like I'm going to destroy
them and everything else and you know
some people said to me this is the very
definition of libel because it's
democracy untrue he's attacking your
income source because of the reference
to patreon or all these other things I
don't want to sue the guy by the way
I've been on the record saying I am for
libel laws I'm a free speech absolutist
but there are laws that we have related
to libel that's the secondary thing but
then on on Monday when it calmed down
when I got home from New York on the
other day night you know this career
you're in my house right now I came home
and my dog was going around Emma she's
13 I love love love this dog with every
fiber of my being
she she was a rescue from Hurricane
Katrina I've had her you know for 11
years and she was staggering and she was
having trouble standing and she looked
confused and Rizer turn around and then
I spent the night and we had to bring
her at the Animal Hospital overnight we
just got her back today and she has some
issues that were hopefully going to work
on but it completely put everything in
Pristina so that that animal yeah more
important to you than this [ __ ]
right without Quentin it doesn't mean
I'm not going to get robbed eventually
ssin but my love of this animal
practices and what we talked about
before about relationships and you have
really I have two dogs the two kinda
crazy dogs but those relationships
matter and in that sense they they not
superseded not override but it made you
refocus on what mattered like I could be
doing all this stuff like that thing in
private Ryan that's scene where the guys
like say no we got to do this we use and
he gets a bullet in the head yeah you
know like now you have a sick animal you
know like your dog is sick and you love
your dog and I don't know I guess it's
interesting I don't know whether or not
having him on would be a mistake or not
because it would encourage other people
to do the same thing yeah I will I know
it would because it's a feeding frenzy
we have you guys operate we've seen this
before with many so wouldn't even
college yeah what do you think his
motivation was I mean I know you can't
well that's no wait what is the
motivation because I believe that it's
exactly what you're talking about
that it's this religious you worried
what was the word you used it with this
religious quasi religious or morally
motivated well yeah that a secular
religion secular really a cases secular
religion that they so believed so I
veered off the path for these guys it
doesn't matter that I'm gay married
doesn't matter pro-pot doesn't matter
that I'm pro-choice it doesn't matter
that I'm for euthanasia right the
checklist to check us all the way now
and and one side is religious and this
is why I talk about the left more
because on the right even though they
know um all of those things
I still get invited places I get put on
Prager you videos I get invited to
college kids that want to talk to me
they put aside all the different I was
at a libertarian students for liberty
thing I said I'm for single-payer
Healthcare lured Aryans don't like that
they booed me but then laughed we
laughed about it and I kind of mocked
them booboo me guys we're the tolerant
one young guys and they got it yeah I
don't get any invites the other way so
so that's why I think that phrase is so
perfect because this is the new religion
it is the new religion why do you think
you don't get MSNBC doesn't have you on
I don't know
I can't beg them I was on Fox last week
Greg Gutfeld who's I think it's a great
guy who's going to come on in here yeah
really doing good stuff we disagree on
some stuff okay big damn look yeah I
can't beg the widest widest Fox put on
ion and MSNBC does you see that maybe
that's a Saturday we wonderful quite on
that demand that we should demand
announcer did you see last week that
here last week Hulk what's his name
after two plays Hulk after that plays
Hulk somebody help me here Mark Ruffalo
oh yeah I said the thing about you know
MSNBC is hiring these white
conservatives and it's so interesting
because he's judging people's political
opinions on their skin color number one
now he's a white guy who plays a green
guy so there's some errands but you know
you must as a philosophy professor an
area there's got to be some deep [ __ ]
there but even putting that aside if
they started hiring a bunch of black
conservatives he wouldn't be happy about
that either you know would accuse them
of being Uncle Tom's or something we
ever finally can part it's like Clarence
Thomas yeah we need more Supreme Court
justices but they're but to like would
you rather have
or subclass Thomases on the Supreme
Court or would you rather have more
white liberals on the Supreme Court so
what do you think is they have to go to
this because I've been trying to push
the ideas of classical liberalism as you
know I believe the individual is the
only antidote to this if you
relentlessly stand for the individual
you will always stand for our
differences you will always be tolerant
of our differences because you will
realize that you're different than the
next guy you won't look at somebody and
prejudge them based on color or say I
have to treat them like there are some
bright mo because they have this level
of oppression where you have that okay
oh you put you put your finger on the
problem so let's talk about the opposite
problem intersectionality is the problem
we haven't talked about that but that
there is grievance jockeying dad said
the oppression Olympics etc we we need
the opposite of internet
intersectionality and and we need Union
allottee and there's a line of
literature called a super ordinate
identities so let's unpack that real
quick have you seen the Heineken
commercial yes it's incredible I love it
amazing everything that I've tried to do
here okay so that's what we need now we
don't need can you just lay it out real
quick for well the Heineken corrected
you lay out the Heineken call they just
basically get people together who you'd
think have nothing to do with each other
or should win yeah right political
enemies or personal enemies and they sit
down over a drink and do it and they
general conversation yeah well then they
they big not sex no no they do some
tasks like this and hard tasks and then
at the end they say you won't have a
beer yeah and they say yeah and then
they talk it's an example of a of Union
ality as opposed intersectionality we're
not grieving we're not trying to find
out who has the most strikes against
them who's the most depressed and then
they get the most to get the rights to
talk the BLM can over over can talk to
the pride march or what-have-you so what
we need to do is oh the shooting in
Virginia right now we need to appeal to
larger identities and we need to
coalition build and I see the left over
and OH
we're again continuing to dig down in
identity politics continuing to use
intersectionality to find the most
marginalized and oppressed groups and
then to attempt to change either the
nature of words either or and the
structure of the rule sets in our
institutions to privilege these folks
John Rawls had this whole thing solved
but I think superordinate identities
finding identities and things that we
have in common and working to build
coalitions and I and I think if we if
the left continues to do that will
either get another four years of Trump
or that other lunatic pants it right
it's we need to build on it's so funny
that you describe it that way because
your ear you're talking about
post-modernism you're talking about
cultural Marxism all this stuff and yet
so people will go well Pete Pete must be
you're right you must be on the right
you must be some sort of evil
conservative whatever and yet you're not
know and and I do more by the way I
don't want to use conservative as I said
the doctor I don't wanna use it as a
pejorative so that's the thing I don't
feel at home i no longer in maybe it's
because I'm oddly situated they that's
another word they love I'm oddly
situated in the Academy and Portland
which is very left to center anyway even
though the overwhelming majority of my
beliefs I would call self identify as a
classical liberal I no longer feel at
home
no with anything to do with things that
are even broadly the left and you and
other people have called for the new
center I think that might be what we
need I certainly don't feel at home in
the right and again in terms of that
checklist of beliefs they have so I feel
that I'm efficient because I kind of
feel like when I live in Albuquerque I
feel that I'm wandering not wandering I
feel that I've I don't have a home and I
don't feel comfortable anywhere but one
of the consequences of not feeling
comfortable is when you meet people who
share those beliefs you have a kind of
ideological kinship you have a kind of
wow we're really on the outs here right
we're really trying to figure this out
we're really trying to make so we try to
live a good life we're trying to be
decent people we're trying to make
decisions in the base of evidence and
yeah we change our minds and
but we're not at home on the right we're
not at home on the left we're being
excoriated on the on the left for
calling out never make calling out
somebody's [ __ ]
a right-wing thing the moment you've
done that you're you're you've become a
farce a caricature of yourself it's a
farce you know it's so interesting
you've hit on so many things because I
love what we're doing here because it's
we're talking about these sort of these
broad issues but then also how they are
directly related to us yeah as people
and that's what I think really matters
and even you know just a week ago or so
and I think it was in Philadelphia they
unveiled their new gay pride rainbow
flag but now it has a black and brown
color bar you know two new color bars to
represent people of color and this is
the height of absurdity the rainbow flag
represented all gay people white gay
people Asian gay people Muslim gay
people Jewish gay people etc is that it
there was no racial connotation to it
and the game community at least from
what I can tell is pretty good on on
most racial issues you see more couples
I think that are racially different or
diverse or all that stuff but now
because they had to bow to whatever that
I don't know if it was directly related
to black lives matter or whatever but
because they had to bow to them they
literally ruined the rainbow the rainbow
is we know what the rainbow is now
they're telling us the rainbow is
inherently part of the patriarchy or
you're racist or in essence it's like I
didn't end the place but here's the
place all right so I thought all this
obviously I don't think I'm blowing
anyone's mind when I say this they
understand what I think but I didn't
even want to tweet about it because I
didn't even feel like getting involved
on this one it's like I have to pick my
battles and if I was available someone's
using your racist you don't want a black
bar and a brown bar on it but my point
would be there was no racial kind of
right you're now making it racist all
right and guess what somebody yours from
now we're going to have some other thing
that they want to put on there and there
you have to make sure they're more
oppressed than you right and this is the
endless snake eating itself yeah don't
it just within that you know I'm just
thinking about Emma being sick I think
that's one of the things that people
don't see when they attack you I think
that's one of the things that people
don't like you're just a guy living your
life you've got a dog you've got a
husband you're trying to make through
the day like everybody else and I think
people need to
take a step back and realize that we're
actually people dave rubin is a guy and
he's a good guy and he likes Heineken or
in and saying yeah yeah bad guy way more
for people and if you have a problem
with somebody it's much better and it's
not necessarily the tone of the
criticism and I you know I feel I feel
weird - Todd or Zach dave rubin does it
you know what I don't think you're not
going to don't exactly I think we're
going to do whatever they want to do
anyway but I think that you would get
more mileage and more attention if those
criticisms were devoid of personal
attacks and you said Reuben said this
this is why I think it's wrong and you
lay it out well as I said before when
people have attacked me - Dave you
didn't ask this question you asked a
question wrong where you you you know my
policy on interviewing is I like to give
rope to let people hang ourselves look I
just ask you a lot of really broad
questions if you didn't know where you
were talking about you would have hung
yourself I in this instance I don't
think you did but I've had guests that I
think do but those eyes those are
criticisms I'm more than happy to
address and I hope that five years from
now on so much of a better interviewer
that I look back on this and think this
is sure I want to be better I wanted
that but if you're if you're going to
jumping-off point is this guy's a
right-wing extremist well then what
we're not going to really do this but I
think what we've done here for the hour
is pretty good we're going to wrap this
thing we're going to dinner with some
friends because we didn't make up this
friendship thing word no it's legitimate
no we're going to do an artifact of uh
say yes when I get drunker wet probably
yeah probably I'm only supposed to my
diamond low sugar diet itself so I'm
only supposed to drink Pinot Grigio now
so I've been drinking a ton of that so I
think that's our I like the red but I
think I'm alright it was a pleasure as
always and we have to do these more than
once a year because I think it's a good
it's a good catch up and it's a good I
have no problem you grading whether I
move forward or or breast or whatever I
think it would be a fun thing yeah and
who knows where our ideas are going to
go who knows how our beliefs will change
when we're confronted but new evidence
but here's what we do know if either one
of us thinks that we've gone off the
rails or that we've made
steak we're going to call it out to the
other one and we're going to do so in
the context of a friendship well said
for more on Peter Bogosian or Bogosian
he doesn't mind which way you say it
follow my on the Twitter although he may
not checkers mentions that much at Peter
Berg lithium
[Music]
you
[Music]